HIS COMMITMENT TO CONSERVATIVES
WITH HIS AGENDA AND DELIVERING
ON THE AGENDA.
IT'S IRONCLAD.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
KATE KOESTLER HAS SPENT A LOT OF
TIME THINKING ABOUT STEVE
BANNON.
SOME WOULD SAY THE DEFINITIVE
BIOGRAPHY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT TOO.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW BANNON
WELL, YOU WROTE A BOOK ABOUT
HIM.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THIS TO MIKE
>> I THINK THAT HE WAS ANGRY.
I THINK THAT AT THE TIME HE SAID
THAT IT COULD HAVE BEEN EITHER
JULY OR RIGHT AFTER BECAUSE THEY
SAID IT WAS SOON AFTER OUR JULY
STORY IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE WHILE HE
WAS STILL A STAFFER.
IT MIGHT'VE COME IN AUGUST RIGHT
AFTER HE LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE.
I'M NOT SURE.
EITHER WAY, HE WAS INVOLVED IN
THESE VICIOUS STRUGGLES WITHIN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S
IF HE COULD AT THIS POINT.
I DOUBT HE WILL.
I DIFFER A LITTLE BIT ON THE
INDIVIDUAL.
I'VE COVERED THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
20 YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT.
AN OFFICIAL PRESIDENTIAL
BANNON DOES      IS NOT GOING TO
BANNON DOES      IS NOT GOING TR
BANNON DOES      IS NOT GOING TA
BANNON DOES      IS NOT GOING TT
WELL TO THIS.
HE PROBABLY ARTIE HAS HAD SOME
TROUBLE WITH TRUMP'S FLIRTATION
HE HAS BASICALLY DECLARED WAR ON
STEVE BANNON STEVE BANNON.
STEVE BANNON LIKES WARS AND I
THINK IS GOING TO GO FOR IT.
HE MAY NOT COME OUT IN, YOU
KNOW, IMMEDIATELY AGAINST TRUMP,
BUT LITTLE BY LITTLE HE MAY END
UP PICKING APART TRUMP.
AND THE PROBLEM FOR TRUMP IS
THAT BANNON ACES CONDUIT TO THE
BASE, HIS BEST CONDUIT TO THE
HE MAY THINK HE WON THE POPULAR
VOTE, BUT HE DIDN'T.
THE BASE IS WHAT ELECTED HIM AND
HE NEEDS MANAGER SUPPORT HIM.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK THAT
TRUMP VOTERS TRUST STEVE BANNON
MORE THAN THEY TRUST
DONALD TRUMP?
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT ALTHOUGH
BANNON IS A ROCK STAR AMONG THE
VOTERS THAT ELECTED TRUMP.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT IF
BANNON DOES EVEN A LITTLE DAMAGE
TO TRUMP, WHICH HE COULD DO.
LET'S SAY TRUMP WINS THE WAR, IF
THERE IS A WAR, AGAINST A
LITTLE BIT, TRUMP CANNOT AFFORD
THAT.
BREITBART NEWS AND BANNON
HIMSELF IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CONDUIT TO THE BASE THAT TRUMP
HAS, OTHER THAN FROM HIS SELF.
IF IT'S ANOTHER TYPE OF ELECTION
LIKE THAT AND HE'S GOT ONE OF
HIS PREMIER SPOKESMAN -- SHE'S
ALSO BEEN A SPOKESMAN FOR BANNON
FOR MANY MONTHS -- AGAINST HIM,
THEN TRUMP CAN HAVE A PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: SINCE YOU KNOW HIS
MIND, LET ME ASK YOU THE
QUESTION I ASKED MATT, WHICH IS
CLEARLY THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
HE'S BEEN DOING THIS THROUGH IN
EFFECT CUT OUTS.
HE'S BEEN DOING THIS FOR MONTHS.
WHAT'S THE POINT?
WHAT'S HE TRYING TO GET OUT OF
THAT?
>> MOSTLY HE'S BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF TRUMP.
THE PEOPLE THAT HE IS ANGRY WITH
HE CALLS JIVANKA.
HE'S BEEN DOING THAT WITHOUT
PENALTY FOR A WHILE NOW.
CALLED TREASONOUS.
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO IS
MARGINALIZE PEOPLE WITHIN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO HAVE A MORE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICAN AGENDA
AND KEEP TRUMP'S EAR AND KEEP
TRUMP FOCUSED ON THE THINGS THAT
HE WAS ELECTED ON, NOT --
TRUMP'S FAMILY OVER EVERYTHING.
ACTUALLY HELP POLITICAL BELIEFS
HE'S ACTUALLY A LOT CLOSER TO